once again it's time to fire up the
mighty Marvel rumor mill pop-culture
websites we got discovered is reporting
that it's wily ever anonymous sources
have knowledge some Marvel Studios is
eyeing Baker Montgomery who portrayed
Billy Hargrove on the hit Netflix series
stranger things to fill the role of
Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe before we go any further we
feel compelled to make a few things
clear about this breaking news first we
GT C is typically not a super reliable
source of inside information all the
websites has fielded accurate rumor
reports in the past it also has a pesky
habit of spreading absolute malarkey
Plus since no other media outlets a
report in that Marvel wants a young
Australian actor for the role of
Wolverine the idea that these folks are
breaking anything but day camonte gum
refunds hearts is pretty laughable
[Music]
second that this isn't the first time
Montgomery has been connected to a
Marvel role but a fandom as recently as
last summer the same website reported
that he was being considered for the
part of Adam warlock in James Gunn's
upcoming guardians of the galaxy vol 3
for example we'll leave it to you to
decide whether this indicates that
Marvel Studios is trying super hard to
find the right role for the talented
actor all that the Internet's rumour
mongers stepped on their own feet with
this one third if indeed Marvel is
considering Montgomery to take on the
role of Wolverine which again it could
honestly go either way we're basically
as onboard as you could get ever since
we got our hands on the actors insane
stranger things audition tape we've
wanted to see him land a major role in a
superhero franchise now listen why don't
you put headway before you would chuck
we literally can't think of a better fit
for him that everyone's favorite
cigar-chomping adamantium mutant
especially after we saw our favorite
digital artist bus logics rendition of
the guy as psyched as we would be to see
Montgomery take over as Logan in the MCU
WGT sees alleged inside sources also put
forth a small addendum to the rumor
which makes us doubt the whole shebang
according to them Marvel brass are still
hopeful that they might be able to coax
Hugh Jackman who held down the role for
almost 20 years and the Fox Studios
produced x-men movies to return failing
vats the sources say the studio would
then
be interested in talking to Montgomery
pardon us for saying so but this doesn't
make a lick of sense when the x-men and
especially Wolverine finally joined the
MCU Marvel is going to want them to be
cast with actors who are capable of
playing their respective roles for as
long as possible at 51 if this would in
no way describe Jackman who in any event
a stated plainly that he is done with
the role Montgomery is only 25 so if the
rumor is true it indicates the Marvel
just as ensure whether they want to go
with an older or younger Logan we ask
you does this sound like Marvel Studios
like at all this is a studio which has a
rough sketch of a shared universe mapped
out through 2028 according to head
honcho Kevin Feige we're pretty sure
that plans are well underway for the
introduction of the x-men to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that no actors of
Jackman's vintage will be sought for the
primary roles it's worth mentioning that
Montgomery has previously appeared
hesitant to star in comic book movies in
general in a 2019 video for gqueues
actually me series in which the actor
went undercover on social media to take
part in discussions about himself he
encountered a fan who suggested that
he'd be perfect for the part of Jason
Todd aka Red Hood the iconic Batman's
sidekick turned villain Montgomery's
response was pretty thoughtful he said
in part I would really love to play
outside of the world that's so prominent
I guess in cinemas at the moment which
is just origin stories and amazing
superheroes that we love he added that
he'd love to quote dive into a different
world that we don't know that we aren't
given a lot of whether it turns out that
Montgomery's got the gut so to play all
canucklehead or nuts we'll be keeping
both ears to the ground for any news
regarding the future of the x-men in the
MCU and as always we'll keep you
informed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you